Welcome back! I hope you had some fun with
currying and tuples and function types.
What we're going to talk about now is
type classes and polymorphic functions.
Polymorphic functions
are functions that are not defined
on concrete types but that are defined
using type variables.
Here is a very polymorphic
example of a polymorphic function:
the function length. If I want to
calculate
the length of a list, it really doesn't
matter at all
what the type of the elements of the
list is.
If I have the list [1, 2, 3] or the list
with 3 characters ['a', 'b', 'c'],
in both cases the length of this
list is three.
The type of the elements doesn't
matter
when I want to calculate the length of
a list. When we look at the type of
length here
we see it length has type
[a] -> Int and that a is a type variable
and in Haskell that is called ... you can see that
types start with an upper case
letter here: Int is
a concrete type, because it starts with
an upper case I and the a here,
the lower case a that's a type variable.
Really what this type says is that
length has type for all types a
list a to Int.
If you're used to Java generics or
C# generics
typically the
type variable is declared explicitly
in the type of the function.
For example in C# you would define
length of t
and then it would have an argument
list of t
and return an Int. But in Haskell this
a here is (since it's a type variable)
its implicitly quantified. You
don't have to
put it in angle brackets or anything.
Haskell is optimized for this case
but the price that you pay is that type
variables start with a
lower case and types start with an
upper case.
If we look at this type here, length
has type for any type a length takes a
list of values of type a
and returns an integer. This is
what you expect
and it doesn't matter what the type of the
elements is of the list, your only
interested
in counting how many there are.
You're not
interested what these values
actually are.
Let's look here: the length of
[False True]
then in this case a has type Bool
is 2 and here we have a list of
integers, so a would be in that case Int
but the length here is 4.
In both cases we can use a length
of type for all a to Int
and in the first case a is Bool and in
the second case
a is Int. As I said
the price we pay for not having to
declare
on what type length is
polymorphic
is that we differentiate the namespaces
of types and type variables and in Haskell
type variables must begin with a lower
case letter.
By convention we use
a, b, c, etcetera for types variables,
whereas in languages like Java or C#
typically we use S and T and R
for type variables.
In Haskell its lower case a, b and c
where in C# you would write List
in Haskell you would write [a].
Okay, here are
a number of polymorphic functions from
the Haskell standard prelude.
The standard prelude is the Haskell SDK
or the Haskell BCL,
the standard library like every
language comes with the standard library
and the types of these functions
reveal quite a lot about their
implementation. For example let's
look at the first one:
first takes a tuple of
a and b and returns a value of type a.
What can this function do?
It takes a tuple and it
returns a value of type a
so really it's quite obvious from that
type
that what this function does is it
returns the first
element of the tuple. Now let's look
at the type of head.
head takes a list of a for any type a
and returns an a. In this case
you have more choice:
given a list of type a
if I have to return a value of type a I
can pick
any value in that list and head gives
you the first one.
One of the interesting things here's
what happens
when you give head the empty
list.
In that case this function will return
undefined or will throw an exception.
That is not given in this types:
the types says that
for all lists of type a
it will return a value of type a
but that's not really true because when
I give it the empty list
it will fail and not really give me
a value. The third example here take
takes an integer and returns a function
that takes a list and returns a list.
Remember, when we have a type with arrows the
parentheses associate to the right.
take, if we put in the parentheses, would be
Int -> ([a] -> [a])
take takes a number and
a list, takes the first n elements from
the list and returns that list.
Now the next function here: zip
is a nice one. It takes two lists
and returns a list of pairs
and the way it works is it takes the two
lists and
takes each element of these two lists and
combines them
into a tuple. Now I think
the type of zip looks a little bit nicer
when you don't write that in curried form.
When you would write the type list
using tuples it would have type
([a], [b]) -> [(a, b)]
There you can really see in the type
that zip
twists the lists around.
Then the last function here,
that's perhaps the simplest function
you can imagine in Haskell:
the identity function
it takes at value of type a and returns a
value of type a
for any a. If you think a
little bit about that
the only thing this function can do is
you know just return its value because
otherwise
it will be hard to work on any
type a.
The identity goes
for all a: a -> a.
The only thing really that it can do is it
can take the argument
and immediately return that. If you're
interested
in this thing where you look
at the type and then you get the
property
about the implementation you should
read
Phill Wadler's paper 'Theorems for Free' and
that paper will explain that
every polymorphic type gives you a theorem
that holds
for that function.
That's a little bit advanced so
you can read that if you want and there will
be a link to the paper
on the course website. The last topic
that we're going to do in the context
of functions
are overloaded functions.
We all know overloaded function, most
languages support them
for example in Java you can overload
functions with different parameter type.
I can define a function foo that
takes and int
and then I can have an overload that takes
a boolean and then I can have a number
another overload takes a List and the
name
of that function is the same but the
types of the parameters
are different. In Haskell overloaded is
done in a slightly different form.
It corresponds more to the notion of
interfaces
in object-oriented languages.
In Haskell
when you overload a function it really
means
not overloading in the
object-oriented sense,
it really means that you're restricting
the types of the parameters. In this case
when I want to sum
the elements of a list, I cannot say
that type sum has type [a] -> a
because what if I
have a list of characters I cannot
add characters together. Maybe you can
say I can define to add characters
but let's say then
that we have a list of tuples...
Well, in that case sum of the list of tuples
of type (a, b)
doesn't really return a tuple of (a, b).
That doesn't make sense.
What we want to do is we want to
restrict the type of
the elements in the list such that they
can be summed.
That is what Haskell overloading
gives you. What you see here in this type
sum has type
Num a =>
Num a => [a] -> a. What this means
is that sum doesn't take
a list of values of type a for any a
but only values of type a
that
are in this Num class
or in, if you think about
object orientation, it only takes a
list of
values of type A that implement the
Num interface. When you see this
notation here
Num a => roughly
If you are a Java or C# or PHP
programmer
or a C++ programmer, think of this
as restricting the values
on which this can work. In Java you have the
same thing: if you have a
generic function you can restrict
the values by requiring
that the types implement a certain
interface. In C# you can do the same
thing...
most languages allow this and
Haskell is no
exception. sum takes a list
and returns it into a value but it can
only do that when the values in the list
support the Num class or the Num interface.
In this case we can do sum of
integers
then in that case a = Int and we know
that integers are number,
so that's fine. We will see what this Num class
is later. The Num class basically says
that you can do addition and
multiplication and so on.
Second one here is a list of
floating-point numbers.
I can sum them as well, but here
we get a type error. The last thing here we get
a type error
because here we have a list of
characters and
characters don't support the Num interface
Characters are not an
instanceof the Num class
in Haskell speak. Haskel has
besides Num several type classes,
you can define your own type classes,
we will see how to do that later
and in this case
the Num class says that you have
addition. What that means is that
the type of addition takes
a value of type a, returns a function that
takes another value
of type a and then returns a value
of type a
but it's not for all values of a,
only values in the Num class.
Similarly,
when you want to compare two values for
equality
they have to be in the Eq class.
Here you see
that the equality operator has type
Eq a => a -> a -> Bool
and finally
there's the type of values that you can
compare
so the order types and there less than
has type
Ord a => a -> a -> Bool
Here are some
exercises. The exercises you
will do on the website so I won't
give you
the answers right now but the
exercises will be on the website but
I'll walk you through this exercise
to get you familiar. So the
question is like what is the type
of the value of the list
with three characters a, b and c
and so on and so on.
Please do these exercises because they
will make sure
that you understand the idea of types
that we
explained in this lecture.
Then here are a couple of more
complicated exercises,
where you don't get a value and you have
to compute the type
but you get a function and now you have
to
compute the type of the function and the
trick here
and this is what I'm going to...
the secret I'm going to reveal
to you
is that you can use GHC
to check your answers. When you're doing
the exercises don't go and
try them out randomly. What you do is
open up GHC and used the :type
functionality to do these exercises.
So you are
sure that you can score a hundred
percent on every one of them.
Thank you and happy hacking. Use GHC
to do your exercises and if you
don't use Haskell
but another language, make sure that
you're also using
your compiler to check your types.
Because we as humans should not do this
type checking.
That's why we have computers to do that
for us.
Thank you very much and see you next
week.